now to army hammer who is bracing for
the impact of friday's premiere of
discovery plus bombshell docu-series
house of hammer completely tying you up
and incapacitating you and then being
able to do whatever i wanted until i was
done with you according to our et source
the disgraced actor quote has an idea
about what's coming he said i'm 100 a
cannibal i spoke to army's aunt casey
hammer who says the allegations of
sexual and physical abuse which army
denies fits in with what she calls their
family's decades-long pattern of terror
were you surprised when you saw what was
going on with him
to be honest with you i wasn't shocked
because it was multi-generational just
awful behavior and abuse
[Music]
my father slapped my mom really hard and
i just remember seeing blood splatter
she told me that everything was going to
be okay
you don't just wake up one day and
become a monster right you're groomed in
a way of what you accept there needs to
be a me too with home as well because
just because your parents give birth to
you doesn't give them free reign to
say or do whatever they want to
ironically back in 2017 army talked to
e.t about being a victim's advocate in
the metoo movement we're here we're here
to listen to you and we're here to
believe you yet in the three-part doc
several of army's ex-girlfriends detail
chilling claims of survival i was almost
fully
controlled by somebody you're his
completely they want to ask who's army
hammer they want to say yeah where where
is the other guy the hammer family's oil
dynasty at one point was worth an
estimated 1.6 billion dollars in the
dock it's revealed very little of that
was passed down to the family explain to
us how that wealth didn't trickle down
it all depends there's
hammer broke army hammer broke and
there's regular people broke it's all
relative
army's net worth has recently been
estimated to be as low as 100 000
earlier this summer he was rumored to be
selling time shares in the cayman
islands to make ends meet any plans for
a return to the acting scene in the near
future army is now back in la our source
tells e.t he is committed to sobriety
but quote his friends are nervous that
the documentary will crush him
[Music]